our uh our old good buddy shanks nephew
made a reply video to us so i made a
little summary for you guys who don't
want to watch a five-hour stream so here
it is a while ago these guys that i
don't know anything about okay and still
don't know anything about made a video i
think about title is true hassan i be
called as transphobes hear why
and then the answer is you know because
we're transphobes transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobia
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobes transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic that's read it
no there's another like 35 transphobes
in there but i'm gonna save them for
late
for those of you watching a little bit
confused you guys don't know who
is hassan [ __ ] is the nephew of shank
yuga who owns tyt the young turks
network and hassan abby himself he's a
political streamer who's always on
twitch he also happens to be a
millionaire socialist yes
what i don't make sense a millionaire
socialist i mean it all makes sense
that all makes sense because it's
because when he says socialist it means
he's into like the redistribution of
chlamydia not actual money okay he's a
little bit different he puts the [ __ ]
in oxy right yeah oh okay i got you puts
the chlamydia in women jimmy
keep up
it's a different kind of socialism but i
think it's still
yeah there's a little bit more of a bio
uh hassan [ __ ] isn't religious but he
does believe that dressing like a thrift
shop manager helps him look like a
socialist
that spreading russian propaganda
hassan's the kind of lefty to get
depression because he finds out his dick
leans right i would say i solidified my
success when i was able to get aoc on my
show to play among us imagine being a
political streamer and your proudest
moment is playing video games with a
vegan-friendly politician and this guy's
not proud of maybe talking politics with
her you know going through all the
the strategies or talking the future of
voting no playing him [ __ ] among us
so basically he's a he's a political
fuckboy
that's what you're telling me he's a
political [ __ ] boy
and i want people to have a more
positive approach
uh to dealing with issues transphobes
transphobes transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic
transphobic with how often this man
yells the word transphobic i just
assumed he either had tourettes or
really want to [ __ ] sweet anita
but
it turns out son's relationship with the
trans community is interesting he once
lost a trans-related debate and people
in his community were rightfully upset
with them because they felt like he made
them look bad my issue as a trans person
is the fact that you a guy that isn't
super well versed on transition brought
on a known transport knowing he might
bring up transphobic [ __ ] you aren't
exactly a vashta trans debate fair point
let's see how humble his response is
i hope
i hope
that
the rest of your life is as horrible as
it is every single day okay there you go
suck my dick i want people to have a
better more positive approach
to dealing with issues i despise you i
despise you more than anything else on
the planet you are [ __ ] cancer that's
my ultimate goal and i feel like i
achieved that you are cancer in this
community and you're a cancer in every
community suck my dick for the past 15
months you've been able to [ __ ] hide
in these ranks you cat boy [ __ ] you are
just a trans person sorry you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about it's
funny how it's always the people who are
like
really left leaning or whoa like you're
trained you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about let me assist
person tell you you don't know your yeah
it's like he's a wife you're just a
trans person he's he's the white woman
version
yeah you know what i mean he's doing
what women do no no let me talk racism
you see you see what's going on here
that's suffering that's the face of
someone that's what he does he doesn't
remind me of the white women who try to
educate me on race i'm like uh karen no
thank you i'm good i didn't ask you i'm
good i didn't approach this topic
no but you don't understand just how
much i want your black penis ma'am shut
up
nobody asked you and we ain't giving it
to you
america deserve 9 11 dude [ __ ] it i'm
saying it what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this dude didn't he go to war and like
literally lose his eye because some
mujahideen a brave [ __ ] soldier
[ __ ] his eye hole with their dick
isn't that how he lost his [ __ ]
dumbass eye because he got his [ __ ]
eye hole [ __ ]
that was positivity right there
hey listen listen listen look as crazy
as that comment is
a brain
[ __ ]
brave
that's good
it's kind of funny you might be just
like that's funny
that's funny but still i'm going to say
this not very positive though
i wouldn't say it's positive more jadin
soldier just stands five to begin with
right there you could be an american so
it sounds like a legislat you know
legacy
it sounds like you were literally
brought down from heaven to go fight for
allah you know what i'm saying
hassan hates america thinks they deserve
911 and doesn't feel like cis women's
spaces should be protected hassan is
pretty much the taliban with nail polish
yeah he actually almost joined the
taliban but only refused when he found
out they were transphobic
hassan once said i'm constantly
surrounding myself with intelligent
people i never want to be the smartest
person in the room uh don't worry that
room doesn't exist
that's saying a lot considering you've
been in a room with grimes okay
transphobic transphobia transphobic and
transphobic transphobia transphobia
transphobic transphobic a little bit
like a little transphobic don't get so
mad about it everyone is transphobic
okay everyone's transphobic
a lot of people have transphobic
attitudes trans people are transphobic
before they recognize their trades they
have internalized transphobia
hey man in case you wonder the reason
why you shouldn't be bothered about
being called trained everybody's
transphobic everybody has it in them
trans people are transphobic they're
transphobic themselves against the world
we're all transphobic it is what it is
the same we're all racist or all
everything
it's a thing
so next
so next time you get caught transforming
just mindful the person call you
transphobic is also transparent the
person just witnessing the whole
conversation they're transphobic too
even though they haven't opened their
mouth you can just assume anytime a
trans woman wins any kind of prominence
it makes it into the news cycle and you
never hear about them getting their
[ __ ] asses beat over and over again
the fighter that joe rogan mentions
regularly is a perfect example of this
they always go back to that same example
where the the trans woman fighter uh is
a fallon fox
had like one or two
uh victories
and has lost
routinely but you never hear about how
much she has lost since then bro you're
lying again
you're lying again hold up you man
what is it which you were in lying you
were lying again hold up he might not be
lying he just might not know and
no he does not care it's woman sports i
don't know why you bring up fallen fox
she's five in one all the by knockouts
in fact she's cracked few skulls through
those victories most of the mma
community said she's untalented she's
just physically dominant
and that's why she was winning so you
use her as an example of like some
[ __ ] conspiracy bro you don't know
what you're [ __ ] talking about and if
you really don't care about this topic
then just stop talking about it because
you by the effort you put into your
arguments we can tell you don't care so
just shut the [ __ ] up
why why because they have advantages why
is that
why is that unnatural advantage wrong
why there are a million unnatural and
natural advantages that people have
never advocate to [ __ ] ban that as a
matter of fact if you advocated to ban
those things sports would not be good
you're just saying it's unjust because
you think it's unjust and that's it
you're not making an argument okay
you're saying it's clearly unjust
without making an example as to why
without without even saying why it's
unjust and if your argument only
revolves around like oh it's unjust
because like the average cis man has
like larger or better testosterone
production than the average cis woman or
whatever the [ __ ] even then you have to
you have to admit that
sports is awesome because there are
competitive advantages otherwise
everyone won't be the same [ __ ]
height
okay
you don't watch the [ __ ] under six
foot league for a reason but you
consider some of those natural
advantages and some of those unnatural
advantages as well whether it be like uh
you know your diet or your material
conditions your upbringing your
development your access to [ __ ]
sports programs anything like that to be
perfectly valid whereas a trans woman on
hrt is not valid is not valid enough to
be a part of the [ __ ] uh athletic
competition against cis women and that's
ridiculous so so i want you guys to
understand that the basis of the
argument the argument is this
people are advantaged in so many
different ways as a result what's the
issue with trans women who have this
advantage of being born males
going into these sports that's his take
his take is we should defile the
category because people had advantages
on every
then what's the point of having female
sports at all [ __ ] it
people are advantaged in every type of
way but that's exactly what he wants no
no what's the point of having female
sports at all in that case because at
the end of the day it's like well some
women are born rich and some males are
born poor so let them compete but he
said it himself he doesn't want he would
doesn't want categories but he's
interested that's another person's
choice that's another person i said that
my bad
what are we talking about at the moment
can somebody fill me in hey man
some males are just untalented i don't
care if they're 25 or 35 some of the
most i'm talented so if they want to
compete with the young children in the
kids category what's the issue some kids
are born rich some grown men are born
poor let them compete you want to watch
10 year olds versus 25 year olds buy
your logic that's how it goes there was
a crazy [ __ ] woman who went to pierce
morgan and you know if you make pierce
morgan sounds smart you are [ __ ] dumb
okay you are like belong in a room with
hassanabe okay
this woman got up there and and we just
asked her
one of the dumbest gotchas and he said
if
floyd wade mather floyd waymather or
mayweather floyd mayweather or mike
tyson
went on hrt for a year
should they be able to compete in the
female boxing category should yes if
they've done the
and i'm just like [ __ ] are you crazy
you would get people killed are you dumb
you won't get these people killed
competing against them
yo
tyson you want to get tyson tyson at his
age
tyson at his age right now
you get him to nah b
no you're crazy this is so brain-dead
you're crazy this is unbelievably
brain-dead you're crazy
do you think there's anybody in mixed
martial arts or any sport who's fighting
in the middleweight division who wants
to hear well [ __ ] it fight a heavyweight
bro i know he's got 60 pounds on you
he's probably gonna murder you in three
punches
but
people are advantaged in so many
different ways some people are tall some
people are short some people weigh more
y'all should fight each other at a
difference
i want you guys to understand how crazy
that is there's not a single athlete who
would sit here and be like that [ __ ]
make sense but these people who hate
sports who do not compete are so brazen
about their [ __ ] stupidity that comes
out of their mouths you know what trans
women are women fantastic but they're
still not female and at the other day
sports is not about your gender
expression it's about your sex your
biology nobody cares about your gender
expression gender and sex are different
though we call it women's sports it was
really just about you calling it female
sports the reason why is about
physiology nobody cares about how you
express in the world so to me when
people say well i think they should
compete because trans women are women it
doesn't matter that's not the point of
why we created the category or why we
sequester women to this segment of
society when it comes to sports it's
because biologically speaking there's a
difference that's all it comes down to
so why isn't every trans woman that's
ever competed destroying every cis woman
that's ever competed why is it that we
only hear about it when like in the
throughout the history of like trans
women competing against his women
throughout that history
you can say like oh man you know i just
don't want trans women to compete with
cis women because they're like you know
they're not female actually like yeah i
got it
what bro you didn't even respond to what
the [ __ ] you said people wonder why
hassan doesn't care about female
athletes with his takes on trans women
it's because hassan is straight he loves
[ __ ] cis women and they're sports and
the worst thing is that we do agree
we agree we agree oh man it doesn't seem
like you do though wait agree with what
but that's not worth talking about if
you go to the doctors okay yes trans
women are women but guess what you still
have the physiology right and the
biology of a male as a result when you
go to the doctor that's gonna factor in
they shouldn't just be like well trans
women are women so i'm gonna treat you
it's a different ball game so when it
comes to risk for certain diseases
different things they have to
acknowledge the fact that you're
biologically male
ma'am
you have ma'am you have prostate cancer
no trans women women what is going this
okay this is crazy what the [ __ ]
happening right now
i mean i guess the the argument is true
like i mean the the title is true
possibly called as transphobes hear why
and then the answer is you know because
we're transphobes
we're transphobic oh my god
at this point you just got left oh my
god he's got it left it's like it's like
it's like watching that like pink-haired
feminist just screaming the face of a
protest like at a high screech or like
that girl who cried when she found out
trump was like it's just absurd at this
point you could you could have you could
have just
answered with a good point let's let's
hear why he said
we're transphobic that is true
and and that is something that i
recognize however this is absolutely
zero to do with trans women competing
with cis women making up a trans person
in this situation to like beef up your
argument
is ridiculous
okay so because you oh my god again are
never the smartest person in any room
maybe this [ __ ] flew over your [ __ ]
head but i'll break it down for you why
i said that okay
slowly we gonna do this step by step
step by step a lot of folks when this
topic comes up say well trans women are
women right which is speaking to their
gender expression right and we agree yes
okay so as far as pronoun goes as far as
like bathroom goes as far as a lot of
stuff goes in terms of like getting
medical treatment i'm with you get it i
don't find i'm not a problem but when it
comes to sports it's a matter of your
biology what you express in terms of
gender has no real bearing on whether or
not you should be in one category versus
the next because it's not about how you
express in the world it's not about
what's socially constructed it's about
biology okay
so i made an analogy in regards to going
to the medical office because while you
may express in the world as a woman in
terms of the risks that you have as a
disease you still have the physiology to
male so the doctor is going to take into
consideration what the fact that you are
male so when it comes to certain
sicknesses i know that me as a male in
terms of risk for certain disease my
doctor talks to me about certain things
that i don't hear when women go so this
is not to say that when they go into the
doctor's office they won't use the
women's pronouns for them or they won't
treat them with respect or anything like
that but when it comes to discussion i
think we can have a mature discussion
where say i recognize your gender
expression but when it comes to certain
discussions and realms in the society
your biology is going to be the focal
point of how we're going to address
certain issues that's it that was the
parallels making the same way when you
were risk for certain diseases we're
going to talk about your biology when it
comes to sports we're going to talk
about your biology not your gender
expression that for this guy is
apparently a transphobic point now you
guys may agree disagree you guys let us
know in the comments for me i thought it
was a very simple point but it flew over
his head for him it was like
mask off we got him boys we got him i
was just like
it's like that was the future moment but
right there right there you really just
explained the point again
what makes you think that he got it
because you just use the same words yeah
to explain the thing no but i don't do
it for him because i think again he's
never the smartest person no it's for
the audience right like some of them
might be persuaded i just wanted to
explain to them something yeah yeah
and let's say hypothetically okay let's
say hypothetically okay okay
that
what i'm saying maybe in some alternate
universe is incorrect or maybe i'm just
missing the point
for you to assume some form
maliciousness to me is hilarious because
i just may not have the knowledge all
right to know where it is that you're
coming from but unfortunately you do
such a poor job
of explaining your side of the argument
other than saying you're transphobic
you're transphobic that you cannot bring
people to your
side really a lot of the tactics of left
folks leading people is just shame
it's just shame
think like we think and if you don't
well we're going to call you a bigot and
we're going to make sure we say it loud
that's it
that's why if you look through a stream
this man yells transphobic like a
hundred times because for him that's a
go-to it's basically like um
it's basically how a lot of comedians
say the word [ __ ] all the time
right when you're unfunny and you're not
really capable of doing really good on
stage you just swear all the time or
every other word because you think it
just heightens everything or you like
yeah it's like hot sauce yeah hot sauce
is great on a lot of foods use it on
everything or all the time and then you
realize it loses its meaning you just
destroy the food itself that's what a
lot of lefties do with a lot of these
arguments so just want to point that out
but
the transphobic part turns into
basically when you say and that's why
they
you know shouldn't compete with cis
women that's the part that's the part
that doesn't make sense which by the way
ironically the likelihood that you will
get prostate cancer
if you're a trans woman that has
undergone gender confirmation surgery is
you know
pretty [ __ ] slim see if you knew
anything about trans folks he would know
that the vast majority of them never get
any gender affirming surgery and only 11
of them get three or more
gender affirming surgeries vast majority
of trans people never get that so when
it comes to disease and stuff like that
they're still gonna deal with their
assigned sex at birth in terms of
diseases so why would you be like well
if they get surgery and there's like no
change like it's a gotcha you don't even
know the people you're advocating for
when you're making these stupid
arguments
so what does it tell you it tells me
that for a lot of lefties they think
they're on the right side so they
approach these discussions not having
actually done any of the reading
necessary to make any of these arguments
right i'm not even that deep into this
[ __ ]
we just spent most of our time just
watching jubilee videos or cut videos
and reacting difference in dating talks
okay this is not even my realm no but i
am half smart enough to recognize when
i'm hearing a stupid person yeah right
and so every time i hear hassan speak
i'm like oh
we got our imposter here's the thing
among us we figured it out let's end
this round but i don't think it's
because he's stupid
it takes his takes are stupid
but
he's not
he's actually succeeding into making
this a thing and banking off of the way
that he does that and that's his point
is to yell it
so loud that he looks like he's
righteous leave it there there's
anything else nah man i think we're good